Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
ahhh
checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you seeing how your work week is going.
I'll tell you right now,
it is a rainy,
gloomy,
um,
Thursday afternoon out here in Los Angeles.
I'll tell you,
but you know,
this is what happens every year.
It fucking rains.
Everything turns green and for like a week it looks like Portland,
Oregon out here and absolute paradise and then it just stops raining and then
the sun turns all of that Beautiful Green Shit Brown.
And then the Santa Ana winds over the,
they fucking like a giant nature's hairdryer just heats the stuff up and then we
have our fires and it's totally 100% normal.
And every fucking year when this place is burning down,
somebody from back east always has to call me up.
You got towed.
You all right.
What's up with those fires out there?
It's what the fuck happens.
Do I call up people in Buffalo every eight though?
Hey,
all right.
With that lake effect.
Snow.
What's up with debt?
What's so with Niagara Falls and he's,
somebody should put a fence there.
Somebodies got to go over
everywhere you live,
there's something that makes them,
you gotta pay a price
70 70 degrees and gorgeous
every fucking day.
You guys have seen me since I've moved out here.
You've seen that?
Just,
just the JFK level.
Beautiful Tan,
golden,
golden brown ginger that I am.
When I come to your shows,
when I was living on the east coast,
I mean I was just like,
it was like a fucking Casper.
The friendly ghost.
If he actually gotten shaped the fat fuck.
Granted my head was the same size as his,
you know,
but ever since I moved out here,
man,
I'm telling you,
people have really commented,
it's like bill for the first time in your life,
he actually look human.
No,
I'm still pasty is ever black and his ugly as ever.
Right.
That's my biggie fucking line.
Pasty and his freckled is ever,
um,
anyways.
Yes.
So this is,
this is one of these days we just want to stay at and eat some stew.
You know,
I love cooking,
but I really hate the fucking music on every how to cook video.
Why does it have to be just,
it's so fucking like perky and everything's going to be great.
Yeah.
You know,
why do I can't get it,
you know?
Any,
do you ever work in a fucking restaurant in the kitchen?
I don't mean being the fucking good looking fucking
dope shoe invites everybody into the restaurant.
Hi,
how are you?
Maybe you'll fuck me if you order the right fucking food.
You know,
not that person.
I swear to God,
so much of beautiful women's game is given you hope.
How far they can get in the game,
how many times they can go around the board and collect $200 just,
just on hope is,
it's fucking incredible.
MMM.
Anyways,
I'm talking about,
did you ever work in the fucking kitchen?
All right.
Everybody back there,
you know,
half the people there,
if they don't have a record,
they're about ready to get arrested for something.
There's always some sort of drugs going on.
Um,
it's,
yeah,
it's just a lot of degenerates in the cooking industry.
I just don't understand.
Or maybe that's why they have such pleasant fucking music.
You always have it staged.
So it was this giant fucking kitchen and somebody just at home and they're
always just like,
I love making toast.
You know,
when I was a little girl,
just toast to me was just,
I mean,
it just brought the family together,
the sound of my mom pushing the toaster buttoned down,
the smell of the bread.
Slowly crunching my dog,
muffin it,
my feet.
I figured on a rainy fucking Thursday afternoon,
we could recreate some of that.
You know,
I just want somebody to make a fucking pork chop on youtube and talk about how
much blow they did in the fucking eighties.
And now they can't even remember.
They can't even believe that they can remember the difference between pork and
poultry.
They both begin with P and my drug dealers,
last name was Phillips.
Um,
so it's very confusing time for me,
but as far as I remember,
sorry.
Um,
anyways,
I worked last night I was down at the comedy and Magic Club on her most of
beach.
Speaking of my lovely nonexistent Tam.
Yeah.
Donald Trump literally looks like he has a halo of hair on his fucking head.
I just don't understand.
Why doesn't he just take their hair?
Plugs are incredible now.
Just take your shit from the back in paratroop that shit.
I Dunno.
It's like he has that.
Remember when Justin Bieber had like that comb over hair cut,
which I really found offensive as a balding man.
You know that some would mock my situation with a full head of hair and I'll be
honest with you,
I don't think I ever quite forgave him for that.
Um,
anyways,
I'm sorry,
I'm,
I'm all over the fucking map here.
What was I just talking about?
It's talking about people doing blow in the backs of kitchens,
right?
No,
it was past that.
Alright.
You know what,
it just,
Oh,
I was down her most of beach doing a show with a blobby,
call him Bobby Collins.
We did a show down there to raise some money for a great charity.
Went down there,
tried out a bunch of new stuff.
If you guys are in La,
if you want to go to a great comedy,
I love that fucking place.
And the people who run it and the level of like comedy Mike Memorabilia that
they have down there is a,
is incredible.
I believe that guy told me that,
uh,
he has something of George Carlin's at George War on one of the specials,
right?
And I like a window or something like that.
I'm almost afraid to say it.
Some fucking loony ticket.
Go down there and try and steal it.
But it's really incredible.
It's like a,
it's like performing in the standup museum,
especially when you saw how old my jokes were.
Sorry.
All right,
let's talk about the Boston Bruins.
Challis bill all belly freckles.
I am back on the fucking bandwagon here.
Jesus Christ.
Can somebody closed the door when they fucking flush the toilet there.
Um,
um,
I watched the Columbus game,
which we lost in overtime.
I miss last night,
which we also lost in overtime,
but we still picked up two points.
All right?
We got a lot of people out.
Evidently like the injury bug is not only hit the fucking Bruins,
it's also hit the Celtics.
Kyrie Irving is messed up his knee.
He was about supposed to be out for a few games.
Now they're saying it looks even worse.
So I don't know what that means.
You know the Celtics in not disclosing how he hurt his knee,
but I think we all know,
okay,
Kyrie thinks the world is flat and he was walking like it was flat and all of a
sudden he got towards starts to,
you know,
go down a little bit and you know,
it's like you ever walked down the stairs and you'd think you're the last one
and you're not.
You know,
you miss a stair for something like that or you think you're at the end and
you're not.
I think he did that walking around his house just thinking,
well,
the earth's flat.
I don't need to adjust to the circumference here.
That's how he hurt his knee.
And that's a true story.
But Ted Denato of the Bruins,
Ted Denato have is Ted Denato.
Uh,
I'll,
sorry,
Ryan did not have one.
I'm sorry.
I'm old son of Ted Denato came up with the Bruins.
His first frigging game.
He scored a goal and had two assists in a,
a overtime loss.
I believe it's five to four against Columbus was great.
What's his face?
A Bertia Ron was saying that he actually,
when he was 18 played with Ryan's dad and Ryan was just a kid and would come to
practice and would skate around as a little kid and now all of a sudden he's on
the team.
Um,
I think they said Burger wants 32 years old.
Yeah,
right around that age.
That's when that type of shit starts happening.
You know what I mean?
And it's like,
you just remember somebody being like four years old and next thing you know,
you wake up and you're doing like Tequila shots with that little fucking four
year old being like,
how are you of age?
When did you turn 21 and the person will be like four years ago.
And you're like,
you're 25.
Yeah,
I got a kid.
He like,
what the,
what the fuck happened?
And what happened was,
is you stop growing.
There's no more
grades,
erotic college.
Once you pass 22,
all right,
that's this weird fucking phase until you get,
until you get married and have a kid at your own.
If you Jiffy of like me and you just went all the way into your forties and
never got fucking married and never had a kid,
um,
do you live in like this fucking Peter Pan Lifestyle where you like,
you still acting like you're 23 and then all of a sudden someone who was too is
now 25 and they were actually married and they have a kid and you like,
what,
what the fuck?
What am I doing?
And um,
if you're like me,
it just causes you to drink more.
I mean,
why would you sit there and like,
you know,
as an adult and try to address just exactly what the fuck are you doing with
your life?
Um,
you know,
but it's fun.
It's fun staying out there for 15 years longer than you should have.
Stick all the stories you have.
Maybe that's why that pleasant music bothers me.
Maybe those people who make those,
those cooking videos,
maybe they got married and like 25 when they were quote supposed to,
you know,
so they didn't,
they just stay out there too long.
Get all fucking jaded laying on like uncle freckles here.
Right.
Um,
I'm supposed to mention this.
Okay.
Second shows have an added from my,
uh,
my tour,
my turnage 50 tour,
uh,
this year,
in the following cities.
A second show has been added March 31st in like a lamb,
I'll like a fucking feature.
Um,
March 31st San Antonio,
Texas,
uh,
stars at night are big and bright.
Bup,
bup in the heart of Texas.
Uh,
April six,
Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania,
late show added.
Do.
Let's go to [inaudible].
You get the French fries.
Mashed it in.
Why am I doing a Boston accent?
Because I'm limited.
April 7th,
Cincinnati,
Ohio,
late show
added baby.
If you ever wondered,
wondered how you're ever going to get tickets to my show.
They ended up fucking show in Cincinnati to come on down and see my red nuts.
Tell show,
tell jokes.
Sorry.
Ben Hacking and stealing fucking material from openers.
Feature accident headliners.
Um,
national.
Oh,
Nashville,
Tennessee second show added April 21st,
uh,
let me tell you a story.
Yeah.
Bought a man named Gary Paul Martin Ebert kept fame page.
So we blame black people and screamed at the Jews and made an evil flag.
What you go on and do Nashville.
That is the predators and hillbillies.
Um,
alright.
Minneapolis,
Minnesota.
June 29th,
late show added,
um,
Wayne bump,
bump bump.
What song is that?
It sets a prince song.
Where did that then?
Duh,
Duh.
Motherfucker something up to something.
Was that soft and wet?
That's my abs after one set up.
Oh,
July 14th,
fucking Portland,
Oregon.
[inaudible] I added an organic late show for all you.
Gluten free.
Fucking Harry cans up there.
Um,
uh,
July 17th,
Seattle late show added.
All right.
In honor of the only guy left alive up.
Bear.
He her fucking freaking from wound Cheryl augur.
Um,
nine 30,
September 30th to those of you not in Europe.
Um,
Denver,
Colorado,
second night,
second show added Rocky Mountain had Colorado experimental aircraft.
John Denver,
you know,
if he was wearing his puffy coat around his head,
maybe he's still owe a third show at it.
Sorry.
Why am I making fun of John Denver?
I always liked that guy.
He was always great on the muppet show.
You know,
it's not an easy show.
Everybody says don't perform with kids or animals.
What about puppets?
You know,
I was always a tough one.
He could fucking just sit in there talking to a goddamn puppet,
right?
The TV screens on you and the puppet and then you're just,
you're sitting there and you're looking down.
You can see the puppeteer.
He's up there doing the fuck.
He's down there doing the voice and the whole time you're trying to remember
your lines.
You like,
that's what the guy who does fucking Fozzie bear looks like.
So fucking weird.
I never pictured picture.
I'm looking like that,
John.
If it's your line,
this is the 12th take.
Can you get through the fucking take care?
Um,
anyways,
I want to thank everybody who's been coming out all right and buying tickets to
my show.
I'm turning a half a century old.
You understand that everything on me is 50 years old.
It's incredible.
By my am I,
this whole fucking mess of a human being is somehow survived for 50 years.
Hey Bill.
His to 50 more is to 50 more.
Uh,
do you know how to do math,
sir?
Hey,
people do that.
he's do another 68 to another 60.
That would make them one 20.
This couple,
you know the odds of one of them making it there is astronomical.
Forget about both of them.
He's doing another 60.
When you say that what you're really doing in a passive aggressive way is
letting people know that they're on,
they're on the back nine,
they're going to die.
They bill.
Here's to another 50.
I mean,
I guess I could make a hundred.
what's the World gonna look like at that point?
Huh?
A bunch of robots fucking telling me what to do.
They could have no sympathy for me.
You think people don't respect human beings in this country.
Don't respect their elders.
You wait to the robots come around.
Metal Container.
All right.
Uh,
I got to do a little advertisement here.
I have you guys been watching the match madness?
I write my bookie.
All right.
I love my book.
You know why?
Cause they're not ashamed that they're a bookie.
Unlike those other people who I know who that all those people dreamweaver's
whatever the fuck they call and try to say,
oh,
it's a game of skill.
No,
it isn't.
You're taking your hard earned money and you let it fucking ride and you're
either going to come out this weekend where in some Elvis rings or you're going
to be sucking Dick down on some fucking boulevard in my book.
He is not afraid to let you know that they're,
they're a part of that world.
To all my listeners,
if you're,
if you already busted your bracket,
there's still a way for you to cash in on March madness.
Sorry,
I thought that was the end of the sentence.
Cash in on March madness.
At my bookie.
If you haven't signed up yet,
it's not too late.
It doesn't matter if you've been a player for years or you like a team because
their colors match your favorite shoes.
Lay down some money and score big on college hoops.
A join me and thousands of online players and start betting.
They actually gave me some free money to bet.
I got a bet that shit,
they gave me 500 bucks.
You guys give me a picks.
Gimme a picks and I'm going to throw it on there and if somebody gives me a
winter,
I'm giving you the money.
What do you think about that at my bookie?
Gee,
are you sick and tired of getting the run around when you're asked for a payout?
Come join my bookie today.
I would only recommend a service that's been good to me and my listeners.
Why are they putting words in my mouth?
I've never fucking used it.
I just liked the fact that they've owned up to the fact that they're in the
gambling world.
Uh,
that's why evidently I'm telling you,
that's why I'm reading this that says,
I'm telling you to make your way to my bookie.
You when they pay fast,
when without hassles.
Well,
there's the other side.
If you lose,
you pay
sneaky motherfuckers.
You're wasting your time betting anywhere else they even,
they even have live in game betting.
So you can place a bet after tip off of Jesus.
Dude,
how exciting is that?
A join now and my bookie will match your first deposit posit with a 50% bonus.
Use Promo Code Bur you are to activate this offer,
visit my bookie.
Dot.
A G today.
Play when and get paid.
Hey,
um,
yeah,
then spend chat and get late.
That's how it's gonna work.
Okay?
No matter what,
you're going to fucking spend you money.
Um,
I've got 500 bucks to play with.
I believe.
Once you guys pick me some winners,
I'm going to put some money on the Kansas Jayhawks.
That's always been my team.
I really got into college hoops in the 90s,
and I just Kansas
and um,
let's say I've always stuck with me.
I just fucking,
I just think it's,
I don't know.
I just always liked the Jayhawks.
All right.
Trump moves to crack down on China trade with $50 billion into to,
we have like the Christopher Walken pauses,
the weird pauses,
drop moves to crack down on China.
Tried.
I can't do walking with 50% tariffs on imported products.
Okay.
Um,
he's basically imposing this tariff evidently because in the past he's claiming
a China forced,
I guess the u s to sh to show them how we make shit.
I don't know if this is true,
but you know,
everybody steals,
right?
Everybody steals,
um,
you know,
like,
it's like,
hey,
Pepsi,
where'd you get that idea?
Hey,
for stripe,
Adidas,
what's up with that sneaker?
Nice design.
Doesn't that look familiar?
Does in that look familiar?
Let me read this article here.
Let me read out loud to give you an x even more enjoyment here.
President Trump took his first steps towards imposing tariffs on 50 billion in
Chinese goods and limiting China's ability to invest in the u s technology
technology industry.
Now I have the hiccups.
I'm going to plow through the hiccups holding my breath.
Is there a way to scare yourself?
You know,
you scare yourself out of the hiccups.
Don't look at yourself in the mirror until the next time you get hiccups and
just that small amount of time,
the amount that you've aged will scare the shit out of you.
All right?
Maybe not.
All right to invest in us.
Technology technol technology industry Thursday saying the moves were response
to Beijing's history of forcing US companies to surrender their trade secrets to
do business in China.
A one to four can sell that a you gotta show us on you mate.
It's Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Do they have the fucking secret recipe?
Now
what do they have?
Kung Pao fried chicken.
How do they do it?
That's like their McDonald's.
Oh my God.
That's fucking hilarious.
Let me ask you this.
Why is why,
if this is true,
right,
why the fuck is Trump blaming China?
What does he blame?
All those fucking cooperation's sell outs.
Who turned over there?
Fucking secrets.
That's the corporation's fault.
Why don't you draw a line in the sand?
You fucking greedy cuts.
Hey,
if you want to sell that,
he goes,
show me how you make it.
You know what?
Go Fuck Yourself.
I remember when I used to sell shit at theaters and if they wanted to pick them
when they started,
like all of a sudden they'd be like,
Hey,
well you know,
you kind of use in our theaters as a,
as a store and then they would take,
try to take 10% 20% then in one place it went up to like 30% I was like,
yeah,
I'm gonna give you a fucking a third of this.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'm not doing it.
Then I just stopped.
I stopped selling shit.
That's why I don't go out there anymore.
All right.
Although I am selling a poster on this tour,
I'm full of Shit.
Ah.
The president directed US Trade Representative Robert.
He lightened Heizer Jesus Christ
is he the great grandson of Robert E.
Lee.
They changed the last name to announce a proposed list of products to be hit
with tariff increases within 15 days after a public comment period.
The final list is designed to target Chinese products that benefit from improper
access to us.
Technology will be made public.
The end objective of this is to get China to modify its unfair trade practices.
Says
Everett s e stat,
deputy assistant to the president for international economic affairs.
Well,
why don't they tell the fucking corporations to be,
you know,
to fucking have a little backbone,
get together and be like,
Hey China,
you know,
you,
you wanna,
you wanna you wanna fucking sell these hacky sex.
We're not going to tell y'all we make them.
You want to cut it up and try to figure it out.
That's on you.
What am I going to sit here and tell you?
Okay.
I don't know.
Who knows?
Has he met with that guy from Korea yet?
I was so excited about that.
The two fucking world leaders that didn't get along with each other and sit
down,
talk it out.
You know,
high some food.
Fight him over.
I'm come over here.
Show him a good time.
Take them on space mountain.
Then left memories.
There'll be a guy,
I can't blow that up.
I had a good time.
I met fucking Donald Duck,
went on space mountain.
You know,
I I gotta I gotta fucking hand job on and ah,
that,
that fucking pirates of Penzance ride,
whatever the hell it is.
The Johnny Depp One.
Um,
I don't know.
I look forward to,
I understand it.
You know,
I've been sending everybody that fucking Michael McDonald does iron maiden and
your kills me.
The amount of people that don't get it,
they like,
does he always sing like that?
Above?
They don't get,
it's like the,
you have to know iron maid and Michael McDonald.
Do you understand?
That's a wide berth.
If you listened to ward off to and the cursive went on
the bed,
he wished he died.
I mean the odds,
okay.
For as much as people on social media always try to say that they have,
I have an eclectic,
yeah.
ECLECTIC taste in music.
Do you member that on my space?
One person said that and then all of a sudden everybody was using that.
I have very eclectic taste.
It was just as fucking,
yeah.
Why?
You know,
it's deliberate,
carefully planned out way to show how fucking interesting you are.
And Open minded.
Right?
Favorite albums,
uh,
back black and muppets take Manhattan.
I mean,
I'm all over the map.
Okay.
I don't see color man.
Yeah.
I actually think that social media,
as much as it's helped me go from the obscurities of featuring in comedy clubs
to the heights of telling my shit jokes in three different continents at this
point,
um,
I actually still think it's a bad thing.
All right.
Because it,
before social media,
nobody said Freebie,
they will weigh less fake tits.
Um,
speaking of which by the,
I can't,
I can't even figure out fucking Instagram.
I finally,
I posted a picture today and then I had to delete it because I,
I thought like the next screen was going to be the thing where you write shit.
So my wife tells me,
kill you got to delete it.
So I deleted and then I fucking,
um,
oh.
And then all those filters,
what filter am I going to put on this fucking thing?
And it actually makes you look better than you are.
You should see how green in Austin my shirt looks.
It looks like fucking pea soup in real life.
But in that one it looked it look rich and bold.
Patriotic.
The whole fucking thing is a lie.
But I'll tell you what is an ally.
The picture that I took
all right with Henry Winkler,
Stephen Root and Alec Berg and uh,
Bill Hader was supposed to be there.
We were a at nerd melt on sunset and they were promoting this incredible new
show that is debuting this Sunday,
March 25th,
I believe at eight o'clock eastern time.
And um,
name of the show's Barry's about this Guy Barry.
He's an f.
Yeah,
he's a veteran from the Afghani war.
And when he comes back to the states,
he becomes a hit man.
And one of his hits is in La.
He goes out to la and it's a long story.
He ended up catching the acting bug and he's trying to transition out of
being a hitman and becoming an actor.
And I can't even tell you how far in such a dark comedy,
it's such a funny fucking show.
I cannot recommend this show enough.
They sent me four episodes.
All right.
And I am Jonesing for the last,
for the writing,
the acting,
everything.
You have to fucking watch this show.
You have to watch this show.
You do not.
You come back on Monday,
you have,
you do fucking stare at the floor.
You don't say good night to nobody.
Papa Greenwich Village.
Anybody.
Um,
what am I?
Some kind of fucking so what bank?
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
those three people and Bill Hader,
we're supposed to be there and I was reading up on everybody.
So,
uh,
cause I haven't done a lot of these interview type of things.
So I was reading up on Bill Hader and they said how um,
one interesting fact about him,
he is the voice for the planet peanut guy,
even though he has a peanut allergy.
So I'm sitting in the back thinking like,
Holy Shit,
I'm going to meet Henry Winkler.
And my goal in this hour long interview is not once am I going to bring up happy
days or the fonts.
Right.
Steven roots there.
I'm not bringing up that fucking red stapler.
I know both of these guys have answered these questions 4 million fucking times.
I want to talk about the present and how amazing this goddamn show us.
And um,
so I'm waiting for everybody to come in at the last second,
right before,
you know,
I'm nervous to do this interview.
I haven't,
you know,
he's a big fucking people and a,
and Alec Berg worked,
worked on like two of my favorite shows,
um,
Caribbean throughZ ASM and silicone valley,
both high high level comedies.
And I was,
you know,
like I said,
a little intimidated to meet all these people and right before I'm going to go
out there,
they show up and they say bill Hader can't make it.
He,
uh,
somebody put some peanuts,
shit like some Allman milk and he's fucking Starbucks coffee and his throat was
swollen up.
He's fine.
The man is fine.
Um,
so now I'm sitting there like,
oh fuck.
Like I had so many questions to ask him and I'm not talking to Henry Winkler a
bout happy days or Stephen Rude about the red staple.
What the fuck am I going to do?
And fortunately there was such great guests.
They actually sort of carried me,
was on Sirius Xm and they was,
um,
I learned so much about acting and writing,
just talking to them.
Um,
the through line with the three of them and just how open they were.
And um,
Henry Winkler has this,
this,
this combination that I've never seen.
I don't think I've ever seen it.
He's like the warmest,
nicest guy while being unbelievably driven
and just has giant balls as far as like ego in there,
you make you fucking choices.
There is no wrong choice.
I don't give a fuck if this choice acting choices going to make me look stupid.
I'm totally committed to it.
Usually people like that,
that driven with that much courage and all of that,
like literally they can be really a abrasive when you meet him,
you know,
that just push and passion.
He's like the nicest fucking guy ever.
And listening to him talking about the like and the fact that he went in any
audition for it and all of that,
he wasn't sitting there going,
hey,
I'm a fucking TV legend.
You should be happy to get me.
He went in and auditioned for Steven Roots.
Another guy,
same thing talking about you go in,
you fucking audition,
you know,
and I was getting advice,
from other people going,
hey man,
you're at a certain,
once you were at a certain level you don't go in and read,
you know,
you should be getting offers like that fucking Hollywood shit.
And I talked to two of them.
You don't get better than those two guys.
And they both told me if you want the part you go in and read for it.
And I was just like,
there is a fucking gem right there then I'm never going to forget.
So thank you to the of them for telling me that.
And then Alec was talking about um,
writing,
which was fascinating to me because I've gotten to do it for the last three
seasons on f is for family.
And uh,
up untilF is for family,
I always wrote for myself.
So I heard it,
I wrote it and then I set it the way I heard it.
And then all of a sudden onF is for family.
I hear it a certain way and then we go to the table read and an actor does it
another way and there's a thing where you gotta be like,
he can't be like that asshole going like,
oh wait,
you're supposed to clear your throat first and do it exactly the way I hear it.
You have to have that thing where you just have to be open to the way they do
it.
And thank God.
Thank God.
I,
I think I kind of figured that out.
Certainly with the fucking actors that we got on an F is for family.
It's like I'm not going to tell these people to do anything any other way than
the way they're doing it.
Um,
but just the way Alec,
I hope you guys get,
I don't know.
I don't know how it works.
If you could go on Sirius Xm and downloaded the interview,
it seems like everything you didn't,
you didn't,
you didn't have a miss anything anymore because it's still available.
But,
um,
long story short with all this meandering is that show comes out this Sunday and
,
uh,
Bill Hader soon.
All this like,
you know,
it's not just a straight up comedy like it's a really like dramatic dark show.
It's,
I dunno,
it Kinda has everything that I love and it reminded me of one of my favorite
comedies.
I mentioned this a zillion times.
It's like midnight run.
And I just loved that movie because like it's crazy as it got,
everything was still rooted in a reality and it had a lot of heart and all of
that type of stuff.
And I,
and this show has that,
I'm telling you,
I'm calling it right now.
That shows going to be a big hit and I hope you guys tune in.
Watch corners.
Fuck it.
Bill Hader,
Stephen Root,
Henry Winkler.
I mean,
you can't go wrong.
You can't go wrong with that.
Um,
and the rest of the cast to the actors in the acting class city gets into,
um,
are all incredible.
Uh,
all right.
I don't want to oversell it,
but definitely check it out when you're not betting with my booking on march
madness.
Oh,
he brings it all around.
All right,
well that's the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Thank you guys for listening.
Have a wonderful weekend.
You'd cons.
Please enjoy the music.
And then there's another 30 minutes of a greatest hits Thursday from,
I dunno,
Thursday,
10 years ago of whatever,
four years ago,
four weeks ago.
I don't fuck,
I don't know how it works.
All right,
that's it.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
what's
going on?
It's Belper and this is the Monday morning podcast and the levels are a little
too high.
Let me bring it down.
Bring it down for you.
Model for calls.
Hey,
how are you?
It's uh,
March 25th a Thursday.
And I know what you're thinking.
Where the fuck was the podcast?
Um,
on the 22nd I was in Europe and I brought my recorder,
but I've got the wire.
Um,
yeah,
so I fucked up.
But you know what?
We're going to get through this.
My 14 listeners that I'm back down to over this,
this rough seven week fucking period as I try to get this thing back up and
running again.
Um,
I do have a new web guy and um,
he is sense uploaded all of the podcasts from the beginning of time,
which is a time began as far as I'm concerned in my podcast.
Religion began in June of 2007.
All right.
With one of my apostles,
Robert Kelly setting it up in his apartment.
So all the podcasts is what we're working on right now.
Okay.
And all you guys,
you send me emails and everything and trashing me and shit and uh,
I actually appreciate the trashing because that means you care.
All right?
So don't worry.
Actually,
by the time you fucking listening to this thing,
when you actually find it,
the problem is over.
Okay.
Uh,
but for those of you who are actually in the bunker and have been able to find
this fucking podcast,
um,
basically,
uh,
we're going to have it all up on iTunes right now.
I have like three different icons or whatever the fuck you spoke,
apps,
whatever the hell you call them,
use that you can click on.
One is the old school podcast with [inaudible].
The other one is the one that I did on Libsyn for like fucking three weeks and I
hated that.
And now I have my new one that I created.
I didn't create,
I paid someone to create it.
CLC,
the white man does,
takes credit.
Um,
anyways,
um,
that I paid for someone else to create that I will now take the credit for and
banish the person who created it to some terrible duty like they do in the
police.
Um,
and I'll take all credit for it,
but there's going to be one icon.
Okay.
This is what we're working towards and it's taken a while because we had to
upload a couple of fucking years worth of podcasts and a,
it's all going to be on one icon and you're going to click on,
it's going to be the Monday morning podcast,
um,
from right now all the way back to the beginning of time.
And I'm slowly starting my own religion because,
uh,
those guys,
they don't get in trouble and they make a ton of money.
You know,
he fucking raped 16,000 fucking kids and uh,
you know,
no one's going to jail as far as I know,
maybe a couple of people are.
I don't really,
you know,
I didn't really follow the story.
You know,
I just heard people talking about it last night at the Improv and then I fucking
threw my 2 cents in to the ad to the misinformation.
But anyways,
all this shit is going to be a,
it's all going to be under one umbrella,
so it'll be nice and easy,
big stupid picture of myself and we'll be back to normal.
Okay.
We had a little blip and I relationship.
You know,
that happens in all relationships.
every once in a while for a couple of weeks,
maybe you move out,
get your head straight,
and it'd be sleep on the couch a couple of nights.
That's what's going on here.
Nothing else.
All right.
I haven't quit doing them.
But you know,
you know,
the one thing that has remained constant is I have been continuing to do the
podcast granted,
you know,
two,
three weeks to three days late on this one when I was over in Scotland,
Doh balloon and London,
London,
England.
And um,
but before I get into all of that,
I'm a fan of the podcast,
actually started a podcast page where you guys can go on there and look at some
of my obscure references or look at the words that I mispronounce or whatever
else.
I'm actually putting some questions on there that I want you guys to start
answering and I'll read them here in the podcast.
What's the name of the site?
Good fucking question.
I don't have it in front of me.
I'm winging it this week.
It's a m M podcast.com I believe.
Let me actually do this right now.
So I know I'm really gonna wing this one.
Uh,
this is all going to be off.
The top of me had a Christ that is even coming up and men podcast.
So what the fuck it is?
Hang on,
I'm typing with my middle finger.
Enter.
What do we got?
You fucking cunt.
That isn't it.
How about the
Oh,
you suck.
You know what?
I'm the fucking worst.
Is it really that bad that people can't find this fucking podcast when I can't
even have the fucking decency to be three days late and actually be prepared?
That's what it is.
I got in,
I found it,
uh,
and I spelled it wrong.
It's,
it's,
this is,
this is the fan page.
It's the MM podcast.com.
That's what you want to go to.
And then you click it on and there's a picture of me and my fucking shaved head
and a big fucking picture of big foot.
Um,
and then you scroll down and they got all this shit that I'm,
that I've been talking about,
um,
on here and it's just going to keep getting bigger and bigger.
That's what we're hoping for.
Gives you something else to do rather than be it you fucking job hating your
life.
And that's what this podcast is all about.
It's all about getting you through that first fucking awful day of the week.
Which is why and me of hoarding my dates out in my stuff and trying to become a
silent millionaire.
Um,
what does the silent millionaire,
I'll tell you what it is.
It's,
it's a fucking term that I just invented.
What do you think about that?
You know,
I could do that on this podcast.
Oh,
speaking of which Robert Kelly,
one of the creators.
Other podcasts.
Hang on a second.
Bobby Kelly.
Yeah.
Not that I'm actually doing my podcast and I was talking about,
I was just talking about how you fucking,
uh,
helped me create the thing over in your apartment back in the beginning of time.
Yeah.
I'm doing it right now as we speak.
But uh,
your voices up against my ear so you're still a,
you know,
you can talk about shit that we don't need people to know about unless you want
to be.
Why didn't I fucking have you on any of my podcasts?
When do you go back to New York?
Oh,
you fucking son of a bitch with your career.
What's the deal?
Are we going on a hike today is the gayest thing I've ever said on the podcast.
Um,
what's the deal?
One o'clock is good.
Let me finish running my mouth and I'll see you over there,
right?
Okay.
Bobby.
I'm doing a podcast and I'm boring people right now.
I'm going to meet you there.
All right.
We'll go rollerblading afterwards.
Okay,
I'll see you there at one.
Yeah,
he hung up on me like he should have.
Um,
that's right.
I'm going on a hike with Robert Kelly.
I'm bringing a fanny pack.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm going to wear a headband.
Maybe tie a Bandana around when my pasty thighs like Chachi on happy days.
Maybe I'll do that shit.
I don't give a fuck.
It's the west coast.
Nobody's paying attention.
There's no reason to,
you know why nobody pays attention.
Do you realize we are at the end of the fucking day,
not only,
not only in this country are we at the end of the fucking day.
Okay.
The though the world,
by the time we're done talking shit in a bar,
the sun's already coming up in Japan starting the following fucking day.
We haven't gone to bed yet.
Is it any wonder?
Everybody out here seems flaky.
Do you know if I wake up at nine,
nine 30 out here?
It's already mid day back east.
Yes,
Bill.
We can do the math.
Well,
some people can't.
You know.
So what is the fucking point of me getting up and watching the news or reading a
newspaper?
Because it's going to talk about yesterday and it's already fucking today and
back east.
It's already fucking beyond halfway through the fucking day.
That's my excuse.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
this is the Monday morning podcast that I'm doing here on a Thursday.
I will be doing another one on Monday.
I'll get caught up.
All right?
Don't get mad.
Don't act like you guys.
Don't get behind in your,
you know,
stuff starts to mount.
You know,
you can't deal with it.
So you take a pill and then the next day,
you know,
maybe I'll take two pills in the next day.
You know,
you're fucking drooling on your fucking lazy boy.
That's how it goes down.
I don't even know what I'm going to talk about this week.
Let's talk about my trip to Europe.
Um,
it was unbelievable.
It was an incredible success.
Uh,
I dunno what the fuck it was.
I don't know.
As I went over there,
had a great time and people showed up and I had a great time.
Uh,
the first place I went to was I went to,
um,
I went to London,
England and uh,
I've always wanted to go there and I have to admit,
I,
when we landed at a frau a have a sweat in here roasting,
baking,
boiling.
It's like a sauna.
I sell mine.
Hey Fro,
yeah.
Eight dead,
a dead mate at Salomon [inaudible].
Sorry.
Every time I say Heathrow I have to say heath row.
And then I just start doing lines from sexy piece.
Cause I love that fucking movie.
You know,
I love that movie because they,
it's,
it's the best fucking a chick flick ever.
I've said this before and I'll fucking say it again.
Okay.
Next time you girls like,
that's really like a romantic movie.
I'd like to see something,
you know,
he just been watching too many of these action movies and it's like,
I don't like him,
but I basically said I'm different and I kick.
Can I pick it out?
Okay.
Can I pick it up?
Like you didn't fucking pick out every other one.
Your fucking Twat.
You know what?
Let me step up to the plate sweetheart.
All right.
What'd you unbutton?
Another button on your fucking shirt.
Give me a little excitement on the way to the fucking video store and I'll pick
out the romantic movie and you come out with sexy beast.
Oh my God.
Sexy scandal.
This,
this isn't like a nine and a half weeks now,
bitch.
It's a fucking love story.
Why are you guys had to call me that?
Because you are a bitch.
No,
sorry.
Um,
that's a fucking great stories about our guys do just,
he loves this woman and he has his own fucking place in the middle of nowhere
and everything's going fucking gray basically.
Yeah.
If you ever watch a gangster movie,
uh,
you know,
one of the reoccurring themes to the point that now it's become cliched,
is there's always the guy who is just going to do one more job and then he's
getting out,
you know,
same thing in the Vietnam movies.
I got one more tour,
dude,
I'm short.
I shouldn't be on points on,
right.
And you know what the fuck's going to happen to them,
right?
And a,
I even believe though,
the Wayans brothers and one of their movies made fun of those,
those,
uh,
those fucking around the way movies where there's the,
the black guy kid who's going to fucking go to college,
you know,
and he stayed strong.
He didn't get in the game.
And then he walks up and he's fucking eating some ice cream and he gets shot in
an alley or some shit.
I don't know what the happens,
you know what I mean?
Um,
so anyways,
this movie actually is about a couple of guys who succeeded.
They did their last job,
they got their money,
and they got out of the fucking game and they live in,
in Spain.
They're married to a couple of hot fucking Bra was,
and uh,
they don't have any kids,
so it's great.
And you know what you're doing when you don't have any fucking kids and you're
married to a hot rod,
you still fuck.
And your barbecue and your lay next to your pool gun.
I,
yeah,
I'm sweat
roast and bake and boil it just fucking chilling out,
having a great fucking time.
That's where the movie begins.
And then
trouble ensues go fucking rented.
I love that goddamn movie.
Every time I see it,
it gets better.
So anyways,
we landed at a fro watching telly.
Is this Stan?
I'm sorry.
It's just getting them noxious like the rest of it isn't.
Um,
so,
uh,
we landed at a fro and uh,
we got in a cab,
you know,
when I started driving down the fucking other side of the road.
Okay.
Oh,
the stereos on the other side.
We really are in England
and we're driving through and I'm looking at England and in London and you know
what?
I'm not liking it.
I'm like,
look at this fucking Shitty town.
I just,
it just,
it didn't appeal to me.
And I think the real thing was I was jet lagged cause I ended up loving it but I
was fucking really jet lagged and uh,
and my girlfriend's going to kill me if I tell this story.
Uh,
this is basically,
this is basically what happened.
I got a first class ticket over there,
right?
But it was basically from New Jersey to London,
a fro a frau,
um,
airport.
And this is what has happened my entire career.
Every time I get a first class fucking ticket,
which is rare,
I get a first class fucking 10.
Let me answer the answer that question before you get like,
Bill,
you at the point where you fly first class,
you ever where you go?
Not even fucking close.
Okay.
Most of those people that you see in Firstclass,
they got bumped up because they fly so much because I'm going to tell you a
fucking first class ticket is 1200 to 1500 bucks a month.
All right?
So if I buy two of those a month,
that's like an extra,
it's fucking three grand on my credit card as opposed to like fucking 600 bucks,
700 or whatever for two coach tickets.
And you know,
that adds up.
All right times 12 months.
That's 36 fucking grand.
Just so you can get on the plane first and fucking stretch your legs out,
right?
So basically the only time I fly first class is,
uh,
is if they hooked me up.
Other than that,
I'll fucking sit in the back with my knees against my chest.
I don't give a shit.
I got the whole thing worked out.
This is how I do it.
All right?
First thing I do when I sit down is I take my wallet out of my back pocket
because I'm one of these guys that has like nine years of business cards,
bank receipts,
Kay.
She Shit,
all this shit in my wallet and right off the bat is so fucked up.
It's,
it's fucking on one ass cheek.
So it's fucking messes up behind my back,
my alignment and a,
if I sit on,
sit on it too hard,
it's like sitting on a fucking stone and it makes me bum a little sensitive.
So I take that fucker out,
I stick it in my front pocket and then I just make sure every couple hours I get
up,
I always get an Ilc,
which socks because people are going to crawl over you.
But uh,
you know,
I don't like being that guy when I got to take a leak in the person next to me
as their laptop out and then they do,
then
we'll fucking get a first class ticket.
You'd do shh of get an aisle seat.
Who's your fucking travel agent?
We are sitting in the middle.
Um,
so anyways,
I get up every couple hours and I do a little mini yoga thing down the back of
the plane.
You know,
I just do,
I've got this little whole stretching routine that I do because I fly so fucking
much.
And that's how much are first class ticket is that I would rather sit in the
back with my wallet in my front pocket doing yoga back near the shitter.
That's how expensive FirstClass is.
So anyways,
so I get this first class ticket from Julie,
Josie,
Newark,
New Jersey to uh,
to London in April,
going to eat for health a la,
London,
England.
And this is what has always happened whenever I've gotten a first class,
at least half the fucking time when I'm getting,
when I'm flying first class,
it means I'm going someplace that's awesome or the Gig is going to be awesome.
And what always ends up happening is somebody else wants to fucking go.
And then they always go,
dude,
you're giving you first grade year to know who was any way.
Like you know,
maybe you could just take a bio,
get to fucking coach tickets.
So basically half the times I've gotten a first class ticket,
I haven't gotten a fly first class.
I'm sitting back there with,
with a manager or a fucking agent or who knows what a buddy who wants to come
along to go check out the gig because it's going to be awesome.
So I never get to fly.
So long story fuck in short is a,
you know,
I spent five months on the road getting ready for,
to tape,
let it go,
which by the way,
looks fucking awesome.
I was just looking at,
that's my new special coming up.
So anyways,
I um,
you know,
I,
I never get to fly first class,
so I get,
I get,
I just totally lost my train of thought.
So you look@oneweekoffoflumosity.com and uh,
my brain's fucking up.
Yeah.
So this is the deal.
So I get a first class ticket to go to fucking,
uh,
from New Jersey to London,
right a fro and uh,
my girl goes,
I want to go.
Can I go?
Oh,
you're going some place fun.
She only wants to go to the fun places.
She doesn't come to like fucking,
you know,
Pittsburgh when I need her
fucking Madison,
Wisconsin.
She doesn't want to go on those.
We'll go on a mat,
Miami.
Then all of a sudden it's like,
oh my God,
I love Miami.
Of course you do.
Who Does it?
What do you need from me?
I need you to love Cincinnati.
That's what the fuck I need from you.
Why don't you come on those trips?
That's when I fucking need you.
So anyway,
she's going to Europe,
right?
There's not,
you know,
there's no fucking way,
of course I'm going to take her.
So this is the deal.
I spent five months on the fucking road with my knees to my chest,
my wallet,
my front fucking pocket,
going in the back doing fucking yoga because I had to make sure I had a great
special.
Of course they ended up catching a cold and I did my special with dayquil.
But that's a whole nother story.
Yeah.
So basically,
you know,
41 year old guy,
my body's fucking junk.
This is my first time going to the U K and then over to Dublin.
And then back to fucking Scotland,
uh,
which I believe,
you know,
I'm a little confused of exactly what is Great Britain and what is United
Kingdom?
It's really fucking confusing.
They got so many Goddamn Ailey's has over there.
All right.
As far as I understand,
Great Britain is England,
Wales and Scotland,
and maybe even the top of a of Ireland with a,
the fuck was all those Goddamn fucking fight and Belfast.
Okay.
Is,
is that,
uh,
is that the United is the United Kingdom.
That is Great Britain.
Just England and fucking Wales.
Is that Great Britain or as Great Britain in England,
Wales and fucking Scotland.
Why don't I look at it?
I didn't look it up.
Fuck you.
This is my question for the week.
What,
what's the difference between the United Kingdom and,
and,
and uh,
Great Britain?
Because before I went over there,
I wanted to learn some of the countries over there,
so I didn't come off as a dumb ass American.
Then I found out there was 50 countries and I was like,
all right,
fuck it.
I'll just learn it over to like Greece,
Romania,
Ukrainia,
Lithuania.
All the anus,
Russia,
half of Georgia,
half a Turkey.
And then once she gets a Cag is Stan go fuck yourself over the hell he's saying.
Um,
I,
I was under the impression that England was a country
and then when I was looking at the names of country,
it didn't say that.
It said Great Britain,
Great Britain is the country.
What does that include and what is the United Kingdom,
the rest of Ireland is and part of it is it all right?
Yeah,
I dunno,
you little ass fucking pieces of land over there.
Maybe you guys got a band together,
you know,
like a bunch of fucking Cubans coming over here and a refrigerator door floating
over to fucking the keys,
you know,
I don't know.
So anyways,
so this is the deal.
So I get a first class ticket from Jersey day for out London and uh,
my girl wants to go.
So once again,
I'm in that situation,
I mean that situation.
And it's like,
you know what,
I got to put my foot down.
I finally did.
I said,
look,
this is much fun as we are going to have over there and everything.
This is a business trip.
I have to go over there,
I have to be fucking relaxed.
I'm already going to be jet lagged and I have to hit three home runs in a
fucking row.
I got to kill in London,
I got to kill in Dublin and I got a kill in Glasgow.
Um,
all right,
so as much as you want to run around and go buy some trinkets and shit,
I have to be rested up for this stuff.
So,
uh,
this is the deal.
I will fly coach with you to Jersey.
And then,
uh,
I'm going up FirstClass to England and I put her in the back,
left her in the back and uh,
you know,
there was some rough waters trying to convince her of that.
And I was like,
look,
this is the deal.
I'm going to go over there,
I'm going to fucking hit.
And then when,
if I fucking blow up over there,
I'll fly is both over there first fucking class.
So because my girl's fucking the shit.
She said fine.
So I'm like,
that's it man.
You see that Shit Mack Daddy fucking pimp got what the fuck I wanted and then
this is what's funny.
Two days before we go to leave,
I get hit with this fucking wave of guilt.
Oh wait a second.
By the way.
Um,
I looked into getting her first class fucking ticket.
You know what these fucking cops wanted?
They wanted like fucking five grand
just from Jersey.
It's fucking ridiculous.
It's so fucking,
it's so fucking ridiculous.
Why is it 1500 to fly 2,800 miles,
but now all of a sudden,
3000 miles big are a little over three 3,300 miles because I'm going to a
different country.
Yeah.
They all of a sudden your foot,
you'll make it like three and a half times the fucking price.
So I can't do that.
I go over there,
I'm going to lose a couple of grant.
So I just,
you know,
fuck it.
And she complained.
She complained a little bit and I go,
are you complaining about a free fucking ticket to Europe?
Is that what you're doing right now?
Yeah.
So anyways,
I ended up feeling fucking guilty and a whatever.
So I got her some DVDs.
Ah,
so anyways,
you finally landed in a safe route and I,
we get off the plane and I wait for her and Shit and I noticed that she's,
you know,
kind of giving me the cold shoulder or whatever.
I'm like,
what's the problem?
And I F I can't remember how it went because I was so fucking tired and she was
pissed because I didn't go back to see her during the flight,
you know,
come back there and we went,
what were we going to talk about?
I was going to come back to him and be like,
yeah,
hey,
there's just flying coach still suck.
All right.
I was just checking,
you know,
cause it kind of seemed like it shot from La to New Jersey,
but I was wondering maybe it got better.
I'm actually in defense myself.
I tried to go back there,
but they had a,
uh,
a velvet rope.
Okay.
And I'm not saying that they had a bunch of Janet Jackson's CDs there.
They actually had a velvet rope there and I was not allowed to go past there.
And I said,
fine.
All right.
So I got out of that one,
so whatever,
whatever.
All right.
So we landed a fro and,
uh,
we get in the fucking car,
we drive over to the hotel and I'm just looking at it going,
this looks a little,
a very gray,
very overcast.
And it was disappearing into a lot of gray buildings.
And I'm like,
what the fuck?
I don't like this.
And um,
and I,
you know,
I took a fucking nap and then I woke up and then we did what New Yorkers fucking
do.
All right.
We don't take tours.
I do consider myself a fucking New Yorker,
but now,
no,
I don't,
not affiliated with any of their sports teams,
but I lived there for fucking 12 years and I loved it.
And,
uh,
this is what New Yorkers do when we go to a fucking new city,
public transportation baby.
Show me where you fucking subway is and I'll do it that way.
We had a company,
you know,
Big Ben Parliament,
Bang,
zoom.
Then we just walk the fuck around and we find the cool places to go to.
All right.
We don't go to the dumb shit.
Like one of my buddies,
when you go to Dublin,
go to temple bar.
That's the fucking place to go.
Yeah.
So I can have a drink with some guy from Cleveland.
You fucking moron.
Go where all the tourists go.
I've,
I've never fucking understood why he would go on vacation to then hang out with
a bunch of other douche bags who aren't from where the fuck you're going.
So what experience do you gain there?
What somebody from Rhode Island is like in London?
It's the dumbest shit ever.
Okay.
You want to see a couple of things like when I,
I gotta admit when I saw a big Ben,
it was,
it was fucking awesome.
I've seen pictures of that and you know,
I'm a,
I love watching Wimbledon,
Wimbledon,
I for years,
I've been saying Wimbleton yet,
yet another word that I'd been mispronouncing a t o n Wimble ton,
but it's Wimbledon done and Wimbledon,
they just said too fucking fast.
So my dummy or is to pro actually not my dummy.
Here's my brain's stooped dump to process the signals from my years.
I think my ears are okay.
But anyways,
um,
so yeah,
that's what we did.
So I saw a big Ben and it was just fucking iconic.
Who's the shit all those years watching Wimbledon breakfast at Wimbledon and
then they,
they always show big Ben and um,
it was incredible.
And,
uh,
got a a,
what else the fuck did I do?
Oh,
I know.
I want it to that the,
toward it to,
uh,
the fucking Abbey road studios fell through.
It's a long fucking story.
They couldn't do it Wednesday.
And by when they wanted to do a Thursday,
I was doing radio and it just didn't fucking work out,
so I'll have to do that next time.
But,
uh,
so I was like,
all right,
that didn't work out.
Um,
I have to go see Royal Royal Albert Hall.
Now,
for those of you who are led Zeppelin fans,
you know,
the importance of that building.
And if you got them there,
last DVD that came out,
it has this fucking unbelievable concert that they gave at Royal Albert Hall.
And I always wanted to go there.
It's really difficult to save Royal Albert Hall.
And,
uh,
it was something that was built,
I believe by this Queen Victoria that I just say this Queen Victoria's this
fucking broad Queen Victoria.
She was into this guy who,
uh,
prince fucking Albert and I guess they were unbelievably in love with each
other.
And the way that they express love was they,
they bought pieces of art with the money from the poor.
That's what they did.
They were so in love that rather than taking all the fucking disgusting amount
of taxes from the poor people and using it to feed them,
they said,
no,
let's spend it lavishly on ourselves
in this unbelievable art collection that we,
and we alone could sit here and stare at it.
It's just fucking,
I don't know,
that whole royalty thing is hilarious to me.
So,
uh,
yeah,
that's what they did.
And uh,
I dunno.
And then Prince Albert,
uh,
he caught the clap,
which evidently was fatal back in the day.
He cheated on her,
but she still loved him.
And a,
something like that.
I didn't really read the story.
You can look it up.
I don't know what the fuck he got.
He got like,
what'd,
what'd he die of in the 18 hundreds,
the mumps,
he got to Berkeley loss.
He got something.
Okay.
He was fucking Victoria out and they'll the great lawn in some mosquito bit him.
And next thing you know,
he had typhoid fever.
I don't know.
He died suddenly.
So she was overcome with grief.
And a lot of people say she never got over it.
And what she did was she built this big fucking statue of this guy that actually
is not gold plated,
but gold leaf or fleck.
I don't know what the,
it's actual fucking gold in it.
And it's got a big,
um,
opulent roof to it.
So the pigeons can't shed on the guy.
And uh,
you know why yet again,
yet again to express her love for another human being.
Why would you help other human beings?
Let's spend more of the poor people's money on this.
It's pretty impressive.
Not going to lie to you.
So anyways,
went over,
we saw that shit and they were actually giving a tour of Royal Albert Hall.
So I wanted to go and it was an hour delay.
And my girl hates tours.
She's a fucking New Yorker.
She's like,
oh my God,
I can fucking figure it out myself.
But it's a fucking building.
So Mike,
can we just,
can you just for me?
Can we just fucking do this?
So she's like,
fine.
So long story short me,
we ended up going on the bloody toe and it just so happens that the London
Philharmonic is practicing in there.
I don't know for a Gig later on that night or the next day,
I have no idea what.
So the guy brings us in there and we walk in two boxes down,
um,
from where the queen's boxes.
Okay,
I'm waiting for the beef is and butthead laugh.
He said Queens box,
um,
the box where the queen sits in
the just basically unbelievable seats and we come walking in and as we sit down
and take in basically the most beautiful theater I've ever seen in my life,
the beauty of the theater,
right as we sit down,
the orchestra begins playing as if they were waiting for us.
And it was so unbelievably beautiful and so overwhelming that my girlfriend
actually started to cry.
So,
and I started laughing at my girlfriend crying because I was actually afraid
that I was going to get emotional.
That's how fucking unbelievable it was.
It was incredible.
And it was in that moment I was like,
fuck this,
I have to see a concert here.
It was in credit and everybody was basically on our tour,
was sitting there with like,
I that I don't,
I don't have the ability to describe the sound.
It was the most unbelievable sound I've ever heard in my life.
And it actually made me less cynical.
That's how beautiful it was.
I actually felt,
I actually,
what the fuck was it?
I got,
how do I put this?
It was like,
I,
you know,
I'm real cynical when I think of people,
I think that pieces of shit,
they fucking lie.
They're greedy,
they're weak cowardice and all that fucking thing.
And then you just see this group of people in this building,
like everything was perfect.
The p the,
the construction of it,
the,
the way they decorated it and the,
whoever wrote the music and then all the gifted people playing in.
It was,
it was,
it was fucking unbelievable.
We will all just sitting there,
it's like something that I will never forget.
And then he fucking,
10 seconds later the tour guys like,
alright,
we gotta go,
we gotta go.
No one wanted to go.
And then he's like out in the hall,
gone.
And then this wall here was constructed by Henry the fucking eighth.
And it's like,
nobody gives a fuck.
We want to go back in there and listen to the band.
It was unreal.
So what,
what happened was we just kept going to these rooms,
the rooms,
the green room where the queen hangs out and has her royal Bush trimmed or
whatever the fuck they do.
And then we would,
we would be in a different part of the theater.
We would dip in,
we would,
we would listen to them play again.
And uh,
this is the thing,
you were not allowed to take video in the place,
but uh,
fortunately I'm an ignorant American and I didn't give a fuck and I brought a
little,
uh,
when I was little flip cameras in there and I actually,
I got some video footage in there that I will be putting up on my website.
Um,
I'm just going to try to edit it all together.
actually follow through on this and make a nice video of my trip to Europe.
But uh,
I gotta tell you guys something right fucking now.
Okay.
Fuck going to sea world.
Fuck the San Diego Zoo.
Fuck all of that shit.
Fuck going to Chicago and go into the top of the Sears tower and go into Wrigley
field.
That shit's all going to be there.
You fucking live here.
All right.
No biggie.
You can drive to all of those things.
Let me tell you something.
Saved your fucking money.
Who gives a shit?
It's not worth anything anyways.
Get yourself a ticket at some point.
Go look up Royal Albert Hall.
If you're in a classical music,
they have a,
they call them prom shows.
I don't know what that was short for,
but,
uh,
they have like this,
this like month or two,
six week period where they just have all these orchestras come in.
If you're into classical music,
I saw another concert in October.
Jeff Beck is playing there.
You know that guys,
you know,
it's weird.
He's getting up there in years and he's at the Primers,
Korea.
Basically what I'm saying,
if you're a music lover,
at some point in your life,
if you are,
if you ever need even into just fucking architecture,
you have to go see a show there.
Okay?
I'm telling you,
it was fucking unbelievable.
All right.
And that's it.
That's it for that shit.
All right.
Um,
unbelievable.
So I'm going to try to get back their book a Gig and,
uh,
I have to see,
and I,
I would fucking see anybody there.
Wow.
Okay.
Let's,
let's be fucking honest.
I gotta admit Jay z and Beyonce were there.
I wouldn't want to see Jay z at Royal Albert Hall.
I just wouldn't,
you know,
I was actually picturing led Zepplin there and like the place was so beautiful,
it almost seemed like fucking offensive,
you know,
for them to be singing the lemon song,
talking about singing poetically about getting your Dick sucked in someplace
that beautiful.
Now I'm not shitting on Jay Z or anything.
I think that guy's a fucking genius.
But you know what I mean?
Like I don't think that I,
like if I ever got a gig there,
I'd want to do it just cause zeppelins been there,
Sinatra,
Jay z and all these guys,
these unbelievable artists.
But for me to go up there,
the way I curse,
it just wouldn't be right.
I,
you know,
this is why you travel the world is you get you two reasons why you travel.
Okay.
One is to see all the unbelievable things that are out there and realize how
much more there is than what you thought there was.
And then two on the other side is to realize,
you know,
as you start to get homesick,
why you love where you live.
Because that definitely happened.
Cause I gotta admit I fucking went hardcore with the food over there.
I kept getting the traditional English breakfast,
the traditional Irish breakfast.
I got a traditional Scottish breakfast and I'm telling you,
dude,
it's fucking,
I like how those people are still walking around past the age of 40.
It's fucking unreal.
Traditional English breakfast was eggs,
sausage or bangers is,
they call them.
Um,
okay.
Bacon.
And that Bacon is more like Canadian Bacon where it looks like you took the zest
of a pig
with a big greater and just took a fucking shingle of pig and through it and
throw it into a frying pan.
So you got the fucking sausage,
the shingle of pig,
and then you had the pork and beans.
And then,
uh,
I dunno,
something else and I got to tell you all that fucking pork.
Basically.
Two helpings of pork,
three helpings of fucking pork sausage,
sausage,
Canadian Bacon style to the 10th power in pork and beans with eggs and toast.
Know,
and then you have a cup of tea.
And a,
I got,
I met dude,
I fucking loved it.
I absolutely loved it.
But like now a week later,
uh,
physically I'm feeling the fucking pa every morning I got up and I got that
breakfast.
And,
um,
what else did I do?
I went to a,
I went to,
oh,
the crosswalk there.
I got the picture of the Abbey road thing.
The picture comes out like shit because you gotta be standing in the middle of
the fucking road.
And,
uh,
I took a video of it.
You got to see it.
It's one of the greatest,
um,
tourist.
I'm not even to do it just to observe it because basically if you're not
familiar with the Beatles,
uh,
you know,
it's a really a shame.
You should listen to their music.
Okay.
That's like the biggest understatement of all fucking time.
But basically,
um,
you know,
Abbey road is basically the four Beatles walking across the crosswalk.
So now everybody when they go there was a Beatles fan that has to have four
people and take that fucking picture.
And the reality is they've actually moved across,
walk like 20 feet down the fucking street scene are walking where they walked.
But anyways,
um,
yeah,
the greatest fucking thing is people stop in the fucking crosswalk cause they
want to get the Goddamn picture,
which I actually fucks up the picture because I think they took the picture
where they were all walking,
but long story shot short,
all the poor bastards who live over there have to,
who live in that part of town and have to deal with that every fucking day.
It's the most annoying tours de thing I've ever seen in my fucking life.
And you've got all these people all
cited.
Oh my God,
it's Abbey Road.
Wait,
let's get the,
I want to be Chad Lanning.
Let me be Paul running around in these and then you just listen to these English
people beep in the home.
If for fuck sakes,
you're fucking codes big.
It was awesome.
The whole thing was awesome.
So we're actually getting this almost like 38 minutes in and I have to fucking
meet Bobby to go on a hike.
So I gotta wrap this shit up here quickly.
Okay.
Um,
so anyways,
did all that type of shit.
Saw Big Ben,
went out,
had some drinks,
had a great fucking time.
And then I did my show and a show at the Lester theater when went incredible.
Um,
I just had an awesome time,
man.
And I want to thank you really from the bottom of my heart.
Everybody who came out in England and London Dublin and uh,
in Glasgow was fucking awesome.
So,
so basically,
yeah,
we did that.
And then the next day we,
uh,
we flew over to Dublin and the Irish people would just fucking hilarious.
Um,
my show at the sugar club went on unbelievable.
And a,
afterwards I was hanging out with the crowd.
I had a couple of drinks with people in this fucking guy's like,
this Irish guy comes up to me,
he goes,
hi,
I love you.
I love him,
but let me bust you.
Let me buy you a drink.
Hi,
love.
Yeah.
Right.
And he fucking buys me a goddamn drink and then he won't fucking leave.
He says sweaty drunk dude with this.
He looks like he plays in a grunge band.
You know what the fucking hat on and he just won't fucking leave.
And he's drunk and he keeps coming up and he keeps trying to touch my fucking
hair,
which I had most of what I have left on top.
Right.
So finally he ends up fucking,
he comes out of nowhere with this sweaty drunk hair and it fucking like pets.
The top of my head,
another man pet the top of my head.
So my girl goes to,
what the fuck are you doing?
And
he goes,
Oh,
I'm sorry I touched his,
we've
no,
I'll tell you something.
I am a fucking asshole.
But when somebody gets me with the good one,
the only reason why I didn't burst out laughing in fucking high five and for how
fucking funny that was a was because he's one of these psychos that if you give
them any sort of,
I wasn't even giving them any of it,
any attention,
he wouldn't fucking leave.
So I actually,
if I actually did,
um,
and then I was laughing later like me and my girl both fucking laughing that he
said it was a weave and it's like maybe because I shaved my head and uh,
when I grew it back I had a lot more hair than people thought I did that he
thought I got hair plugs or or or something.
But Oh man,
it was fucking hilarious.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
that was Dublin that we,
that was only on dove for like two seconds.
We've got this hilarious cab driver and he was driving us to the airport and
all,
and by the way,
all these Scottish guys were over there cause they had this huge rugby match and
I totally got into the rugby over there.
They got this league,
the uh,
the six nations league that I think is Scotland,
Wales,
England as it three,
Ireland,
France and Italy.
Uh,
there's only 16,
so reminded me of hockey like the fucking original six.
There's not that many players.
He can get to know the teams.
So long story short,
if Ireland won the game the day we were leaving,
if Ireland when the game than they were the champions of the league and if
Scotland lost,
they would be the worst team in the league.
Thus winning the wooden spoon,
wooden spoon,
they actually give you a fucking award.
It's like,
like you don't know that you are the worst just in case you forget in Noda rugby
,
they give you something called the wooden spoon,
you know,
just so people can fucking rub that.
I think that's brilliant.
Fucking brilliant.
I think it's hilarious because that's such a great way to give like a team shit.
Like take the Pittsburgh pirates.
How many fucking wooden spoons would they,
they would be like the New York Yankees of wooden spoons and it's just a whole
nother level to give somebody shit.
So basically when we were over there,
all these squats came over to watch the game and uh,
all the Irish people were talking shit.
I was just fucking gray talking about their,
their,
their kilts in O and.
M.
So I got so amped up by watching these guys give each other shit and I wasn't
getting any American sports that I had when I landed in Scotland.
The the next day I actually watched the game and it was a fucking great game in
Scotland won.
They actually won and avoided getting the wooden spoon and Ireland actually lost
the championship because of that.
And I believe France one with,
it's just something wrong about French people winning a rugby contents,
you know,
championship.
Considering the stereotype of them and considering I'd never been there,
wait a minute,
this guy wasn't Andre the giant French.
The fuck is wrong with me.
I'm such an idiot.
All right,
scratch all that,
whatever.
So I got into it and um,
then my last night there,
I um,
I went to a,
the Lyons Theatre in Glasgow,
Scotland and uh,
you know,
I was so tempted to go out there but I didn't want to fuck my show up by pissing
everybody off.
But I really wanted to go up and open with,
rather than be like,
hey,
how are you guys doing?
I really appreciate you coming out.
Cause you don't know who the hell I am.
I really felt like coming out there and just going,
how are you doing your fucking skirt?
Wearing could just open it up
just to see what they do.
And I realized halfway through the show that they probably would have laughed.
But,
uh,
I got great video of all of them.
Uh,
they,
I got the whole crowd saying,
you're,
you're listening to the Monday morning podcast.
You fucking cons.
But she can understand what they're saying because there's too many of them.
I had my heart in the right place.
Um,
maybe I'll put it up with some actual,
uh,
what they subtitles underneath it.
You're watching the,
yeah,
you're listening to the Monday morning podcast.
You're fucking code.
They really leaned into it too.
I'll put the video,
it's all gonna be part of the video.
But I sincerely want to thank everybody who came out to see my shows.
I was unbelievably flattered
by the,
uh,
the reception I got when I was over there.
Like,
people were actually clapping,
like they knew who I was and it was incredible.
And that was another thing that I learned when I was over there was the,
uh,
like the different levels of fame.
Like over here I have a,
like I say,
I have notoriety.
That's where I'm at,
you know,
second degree notoriety.
Like every once in a while someone was like,
Hey,
that comedian guy.
Right.
Eh,
thank you.
Funny.
I,
I used to be on a,
you're on that show right?
Once you on that show.
Yeah,
yeah.
It was on this show.
Um,
but just to go over there and see,
I said,
like John Mayer had a sold out show at Wembley Stadium and added a second show.
And I was like,
wow,
that fucking dude is famous.
Okay.
And um,
you know,
when we get into the entertainment game and as a performer,
when you start,
you know,
trying to sell tickets,
and the first time you sell out a fucking comedy club,
you can't believe it.
And just to see someone to be able to move that amount of tickets on the other
side of the fucking world,
it's,
it's unreal.
For those of you unfamiliar with Wembley Stadium,
this is how big it is.
Evil Knievel did a stunt there.
He fucking jumped over like,
like 30 buses.
London double deckers.
Granted he didn't fucking make it,
but just picture how fast you'd have to get a motorcycle going today.
Forget about a motorcycle 40 fucking years ago or 35 years ago.
That probably weighed two tons.
Yeah.
And he bet he cleared the buses.
I think he landed on the last one.
That's a hit.
That's some footage right there that you might want to check all you x game
people cause he's the fucking father,
all of that shit.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
John Mayer sold that fucking place out in these,
these,
he's got another one coming up,
added a show there.
So I was really a humbled going over there and um,
and I'm looking forward to coming back again,
going to a concert at Royal Albert Hall.
Go into rugby game and either Scotland or
a fucking Ireland and just coming through all those again.
I definitely want to build up a following over there.
Cause I had a great time after actually actually after my,
my Gig in the Lyons theatre,
I went over to um,
this,
this comedy club and dude,
it was fucking hilarious.
Uh,
we walked in there and we will listen to the host of the show and the guy is
speaking English and we cannot understand 80% of what he's saying.
So we're laughing along with the crowd,
not at the jokes,
just because fuck fucking hold Ridge Hagen rejected a fucking hotel room.
It's like what you guys remember that when,
when in snatch,
when Brad Pitt play that Irish character,
you couldn't understand.
This was the Scottish Scotland version of that.
And I met this comedian Kevin Bridges,
who's I guess huge over there.
Not even guess.
He is huge over there.
Afterwards we have a couple of pints
and um,
I started talking about the word cunt and I was too drunk.
I wish I filmed it.
Listening to these guys talk about the word content,
the way they say it would have been so perfect on this podcast at some point.
I have to,
I have to interview one of those two guys on this podcast.
But,
um,
I was sitting there going,
yeah,
we're like blown away how you guys can just say cunt and it's not offensive.
And they're like,
Yo,
hi,
everybody says that when they come over here,
blah,
and all this shit.
Right?
So I was talking to him,
I'm like,
yeah,
you actually use it as like,
like a compliment.
You say stuff like,
Oh,
you know,
he's,
he's a good client.
And the other guy goes,
he goes,
oh,
he's a great content top couldn't,
so there you go.
There's a new expression for you.
He's a top client.
I think that's the greatest things I've ever heard.
So I'm,
I'm saying to these guys,
um,
ah,
fuck,
why did I film?
You would have loved this shift if you're a stand up geeky didn't want to you,
you just want to see like we would trade notes like I was saying.
So I go,
so what is basically the c word?
What is the word you can't say over in Scotland?
And he said,
uh,
spastic is what he said spastic.
And he tried.
He was explaining to me,
but,
but granted,
we were both fucking shit faced and I could barely understand what this dude was
saying when we were both sober.
Right.
But he was,
I guess it means I couldn't figure it meant some form of like a retarded slash
vegetable and like,
I dunno like that.
They just don't,
you just,
you don't talk about that stuff over there.
If you do,
I guess it's literally needle going off the fucking record player.
But um,
so I thought that that was really a,
I thought that that was interesting.
What else?
Oh,
here's something you guys better brace yourselves for as far as pop culture
thing that I saw over there on their American idol over there.
Um,
there's a,
there's this
wins and they got these high top fades like that dude from kid and play.
Um,
I think it was play the light skin dude,
right?
With the fucking high top for that fucking beyond that.
The eraser head fade,
right?
Two white kids,
they both have that do,
they're twins named John and Edward and they go by the name Jedward I sweat
and they're really into vanilla ice.
They think vanilla ice is awesome.
And the reporter was going,
you know,
people kind of ridiculed him and they're like,
oh,
but when he freestyles,
he's lethal.
So I didn't even have to hear what the fuck they sing.
I just know that some shit is so bad.
It's fucking awesome.
So I'm just just telling you to get prepared for that because I think that that
could go global.
That's it's like the perfect storm of fucking awful.
So do you remember you heard it here first in the states.
Watch out for Jedward look them up if you have to.
Um,
all right,
we're 50 minutes into this thing.
I got fucking rap.
This fucking thing up.
What did I want to talk about?
I have any fucking,
any other stories?
Whatever.
This is just the English podcast.
I'll give you one fucking overrated,
underrated thing that's really annoying.
The shit out of me is this whole thing.
Then when you go in to get a fucking Burrito,
all right,
or a Taco and they asked you what toppings you want and you get whatever
toppings you want.
Then all of a sudden if you want to get Guacamole,
this whole bullshit,
that Guacamole's extra,
oh that's 50 cents extra.
That's a dollar extra.
Like Avocados are fucking rare.
Maybe on the east coast,
but I got to admit I got a two friends of mine who own houses out here.
They got fucking avocado trees in their goddamn yard.
They just,
it's one of those things where just like diamonds,
I always,
you always hear that rumor that diamonds aren't really rare.
They just say they are and they just control how many go out.
That's what they're trying to do with fucking guacamole.
I put up with it.
It was one kind of fucking food.
I didn't give a shit.
I paid extra for the Guacamole.
I didn't give a fuck and you know what I did?
I came by,
became part of the mechanism that created that new corporate fucking cogent way
of,
uh,
making an extra money.
And I'll tell you why,
because you know what?
I got a breakfast sandwich the other day and Bacon was extra,
you know,
like all of a sudden,
that's his big fucking commodity.
So you can add that to your fucking list of over priced,
overpriced fucking bullshit.
Disposable razors locked up behind the fucking counter,
like their jewels,
orange juice,
guacamole,
and fucking now bacon self.
This is what we gotta do.
Everybody,
the 14 fucking people,
if they say it's extra,
be like,
you know what,
that,
I don't want it.
Why don't you sit on your fucking vacant?
Let's smell it going bed.
That's it.
I'm not playing fucking ball.
Only time I'm fucking getting guacamole's on home and I'll make it myself.
Or if these fucking cunts don't charge me any extra money,
but you know what they'll do,
right.
You know what they'd do?
They'll be like,
all right,
it's not extra anymore,
but the fucking Burrito is 50% more and they'll play on nine
11 because of nine 11.
They always win.
There's the last thing I want to tell you.
This is the one thing I loved about Scotland.
You know,
they say whores over there.
They say,
hires these fucking hours doing drugs.
The floor was the flower.
I'm fucking up the accent.
Well,
these folk in hires doing drugs,
her's whores hat,
Jelly.
They said,
I fucking loved it.
I loved every fucking second of it.
Um,
that's it.
That's the end of the podcast.
I got some shit I got to fucking do.
I apologize that this thing was so late,
but I'm telling you,
you know,
good things come to those who fucking wait,
I think this was a great podcast.
I'm gonna Pat Myself on the back.
Listen to this.
That was make,
it's really fucking the back of my neck,
my spine area.
That fucking hurt.
All right,
you guys have a great week.
God bless and don't worry.
It's a little rough time here.
It's sort of a podcast,
recession.
We're riding our way through it.
All right.
I'll talk to your fucking constantly.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].